what are some of the takeaways that you
are going to be talking more about today
well i think a group of scientists
across the world have come together to
give some clear takeaways for leaders
one is that 1.5 degrees centigrade is
both important and achievable but it's
only achievable if we take action now to
get steep reductions in emissions by
2030 and continue that through to 2050.
so that's a key message
it's also going to be very dependent
upon research and development the
application of technologies scaling them
and putting them in place now and
natural solutions and of course
investment in technologies for the
future those are all key and of course
all the little things that we do as
individuals help as well to try and get
this in the right place so this is
achievable but requires urgent action
right the way across the globe
so as i know you said that we should eat
less meat i had the chancellor on this
morning he was in a meat market and he
said no we could eat as much meat as we
want basically
well my point is that i'm i'm reduce my
meat consumption i think little things
like cutting down on meat i cycle to
work active transport i think is
important rather than using cars where
we don't have to i think that taking a
decision to reduce the amount you fly
which is something again i've done those
little things which are not major
changes that little thing all add up
across millions of people to make a
difference they're not the solution but
they're part of the solution so the
behavioral changes we make are going to
be critically important as we go into
this and of course the technologies are
going to be really important to get this
at scale the things that we need at
scale from home heating through to
electric vehicles through to
new sustainable aircraft fuels through
to industry cement and the other things
that add to the carbon burden those are
all going to be important technological
changes which need to be implemented
right the way across the globe and there
are things you can do now and we must do
now
and you said one of those is to fly less
i also put that to the chancellor
because of course as you know it's
cheaper to fly from today nationally
because he has
reduced the air passenger duty for for
people who want to fly internally um
that must be very frustrating given that
you're advising them on this sort of
thing
well i think again
you know i've talked about what i see as
a series of of choices that we can make
and i think individuals right the way
across the world are making those
decisions this is not a uk specific
issue this is a global issue for
governments right the way across the
world and it's for individuals right the
way across the world so we've got to get
the technologies in place we've got to
move to make the green choice the easy
choice and that is a bit about
technological improvement it's obviously
about cost and it's about accessibility
those things need to happen which are
both industry government and personal
choices and there are things that we can
do as individuals and and you know i've
said the sorts of things that i'm doing
that i think will be things that if done
across
millions and we know lots of people are
doing that they will make a difference
yeah but every little helps as you're
saying and yet the government that you
you know you're the chief scientific
advisor and they go they're flying in
the face of two of the things that
you've just talked about my my own point
is that you know you must find that
frustrating sir
well i think if you look at the letter
that that has been signed by over 40
countries and that ranges from um island
small islands to uh
countries in the global south global
north big countries small countries
senior science advisers right the way
across the world are giving a pretty
consistent message on this there isn't
much disagreement as to what needs to be
done and that's for governments right
the way across the world to pick up and
take notice of and our job is to make
sure the science advice is as clear as
it can be i believe it is clear with the
uncertainties expressed and then of
course it's up to politicians elected
democratic politicians to make the
choices as to what they what they wish
to do to get there and i think you know
there is not an inconsistency between um
between the availability of something
and how much you choose to use it those
those are things that need to be
need to be taken into account and i
think as i say the absolutely key
message is there are actions that must
be taken now over this decade which
involve research and development to get
there that will make a difference to get
steep reductions in emissions right the
way across the globe by 2030.
um how will the boats that you're on
today help
well this is a fantastic ship we've got
to call it a ship not a boat and it's a
ship that
carries a long tradition of polar
research and the scientists will be
looking at things like the cryosphere so
the ice mass uh ice shelves glaciers
sea levels ocean currents atmospheric
analysis
analysis of life in the polar region
these are all really crucial things and
if you think back to the climate story
science picked up the signals science
was the diagnostician that said there's
something going on here we need to worry
about and it's man-made science is also
the treatment it's the way in which we
can take the actions to reduce the
climate change and of course to take the
action to adapt to it which is equally
important because if we don't adapt to
make sure that we protect ourselves
there's going to be a problem
okay you say it's the ship sir patrick
but i know to all my viewers it will be
forever boaty mcboatface let's be honest
let me just ask you before i
let me just ask you before i let you go
um covered um are we winning the battle
finally
well i think that the vaccines have made
an absolutely massive difference and now
we also have antiviral medicines coming
along we've definitely got the
armamentarium we need to tackle this now
keeping immunity high is really really
important it's not gone across the world
it's still very high levels in all sorts
of places we have high levels in the uk
but we are much more protected against
it and that is the key thing so keep the
protection up keep the immunity up and
hopefully drive the levels down and
and we we're a bit uncertain as to which
direction the levels go at at the moment
so i think we've got a pretty difficult
winter ahead of us
good to talk to you patrick thank you
for joining us